a declare le tocó lidiar con un sistema
internacional bastante particular con el
fin de la guerra fría que en la cual
sudáfrica había sido fundamental para
luchar contra el comunismo en el sur de
áfrica particularmente en la media cola
mozambique pero el fin de la grafía le
permitió a él empezar a hacer unos
cambios en sudáfrica que fueran
determinantes y que llevarían al al fin
del régimen del apartheid y la suma del
contexto internacional más las sanciones
internacionales y lo inviable que se
había convertido el régimen del
apartheid lo ubican como un personaje un
poco conflictivo en la medida en que él
participó en el régimen de la partida y
durante muchos años fue ministro de
defensa fue ministro de relaciones
exteriores del régimen del apartheid y
llega a al poder hacer unos cambios que
él ve necesarios y que ve fundamentales
en una sudáfrica que ya no podía seguir
con seguir con ese régimen político
bueno y se han producido numerosas
condolencias tras la muerte de klerk
pero también surgen declaraciones que
critican su gestión no sólo como líder
sino también su papel tras dejar el
poder asegurando que tuvo muchas
oportunidades para admitir la amplia
total del daño causado por el apartheid
y nunca las aprovechó cuál es su visión
al respecto
como les decía es un personaje muy
conflictivo porque hay mucha gente que
está a favor de su obra y mucha gente
que está en contra de su obra 'el
reconoció muchas veces los crímenes que
se habían cometido durante la partida
pero nunca condenó activamente
abiertamente al régimen del apartado de
hecho es interesante ver como él cuando
sale de la presidencia y eligen a
mandela él es vicepresidente de
sudáfrica durante durante un par de años
en la presidencia de mandela y después
sale e incluso tiene confrontaciones en
medios de comunicación en twitter y en
facebook etcétera con desmond tutu que
es otro premio nobel de paz
importantísimo en la historia de
sudáfrica justamente por porque él a
pesar del cambio siempre defendió el
papel que jugaron los blancos y digamos
la grandeza que tuvieron los blancos
para reconocer sus errores y como decía
él para darle cederle el poder a sus
antiguos enemigos entonces las críticas
vienen justamente por eso por su
incapacidad
de mostrar un poco más de solidaridad
frente a la población negra y por su
incapacidad para reconocer
las atrocidades y repudiar el régimen de
la parte de que el super declare que
dejó un vídeo póstumo en el que pide
perdón una vez más por la segregación
racial en sudáfrica en las imágenes dice
que se siente orgulloso de la
constitución de esta nación pero a la
vez se siente profundamente preocupado
por la vulneración de muchos aspectos de
la carta magna a qué se refiere cuál es
la situación que está viviendo el país
en estos momentos
a ver de klerk y mándela i desmond tutu
nos hablan de una sudáfrica de la nación
arcoiris de la sudáfrica de la
reconciliación incluso a nivel
internacional sudáfrica se presenta como
la gran estrella en términos de
resolución de conflictos sin embargo más
de dos décadas después de la terminación
de la partida y sudáfrica sigue
enfrentando un apartado económico que es
claro sigue habiendo una una desigualdad
muy grande en sudáfrica sigue habiendo
un desempleo de casi el 30 por ciento y
la situación de uno de gran parte de la
población negra no ha mejorado en los
últimos años quiere decir que la
constitución nos nos reúne los derechos
fundamentales de los que hablaron de
klerk y mándela durante el proceso de
redacción de la nueva constitución pero
la realidad es diferente y el congreso
nacional africano el partido de gobierno
que se había comprometido a eliminar
esas esas secuelas sobre todo las
económicas de la pantalla no ha sido tan
exitoso en el proceso entonces estamos
hablando de una sudáfrica que
indiscutiblemente está mejor que cuando
el apartado pero que todavía tiene un
largo camino por recorrer en términos de
igualdad entre blancos y negros de
oportunidad económica de empleo de
acceso a salud a educación incluso a
infraestructura tiene unos problemas de
energía muy complicados
y baladas y con esto termino unos
problemas de corrupción muy muy fuertes
que hacen que la situación sea mucho más
complicado